this furniture and lighting aren't in a
museum even if at first it all looks
like something from a bygone era
combining tradition with the latest
trends to make something both classical
and contemporary is Lee brooms trademark
since 2007 he's been designing home
furnishings and developing concepts
under his own label sometimes it's kind
of like i used the idea of a modern
aesthetic with a traditional material or
vice versa so it's kind of I like to
kind of play between the two styles the
idea is is that we're sort of creating
pieces that are almost like future
antiques this chair is typical of Lee
brooms word the upholstered furniture
comes from his salon collection the
style is reminiscent of the elegance of
the 1930s while the studs are a touch of
today but with the price of several
thousand euros it'll be in use for more
than one season
back when he was seventeen broom won a
design competition that allowed him to
work for British fashion icon Vivienne
Westwood he then went on to study
fashion design at the prestigious
central saint martins college of art and
design when I was absent martens and
studying in London it's expensive as a
student so you kind of have to find ways
of means of kind of surviving and I
didn't want to work in a store and
didn't want to work in a club so I
decided to go around two local bars and
restaurants and say you know can I make
you some curtains or do some upholstery
or you know stuff like that will make
mirror frames and it became a cottage
industry and it grew and it grew and
then I was given a a bar to design from
beginning to end and from that point
really was kind of my introduction into
kind of interiors he attracted
international attention in 2012 with his
crystal bowl a lightbulb made of cut
glass with light provided by LEDs it
became a best-seller exported to 26
countries
brent produced his first crystal bulbs
at Cumbria crystal the last crystal
glass works in Britain it was a simple
logistical decision but median Britain
unexpectedly became an essential part of
the brand's appeal nowadays he tries to
produce up to eighty percent of his
products domestically
it's an interesting way of working as
well you know some of these people have
been doing this job in a certain way for
many years and then somebody like me
comes along and then sort of says all we
should do put carpet inside a light and
they're kind of like well with this this
is sort of insane but as soon as they're
on board with the idea as soon as you
get the enthusiasm then you can make it
happen so it's amazing for me because
I'm learning the technique and the craft
from them and it's great for them
because they're creating something that
they've never done before in like 40
years brooms designs can also be found
at Harrods last spring he designed the
sales area for the French shoe designer
Christian Louboutin at the prestigious
London department store around 40 shops
bars and restaurants now barely brooms
touch
I kind of think when you walk into that
environment part of what you're wanting
to do is kind of escape and I like that
idea of escapism and taking somebody on
a bit of a journey at 37 Lee broom is
still at the beginning of his career and
he's living proof that some things never
go out of style